what's going on everyone in this video
i'm going to show you how to raise your
prices in a tactical way on your
existing customers
so it's one thing to raise your prices
on new customers which for many times
you know that's
something that you have to do uh because
you need to you know you want to
reinvest in
making the business better you want to
cover some capital expenses or you just
want to make more money
which is fine and the number one lever
on making money is what you're pricing
at
right we've done this in thousands of
businesses now
and there's a process that we go about
this because if you raise it on existing
customers
be ready to have people be upset but
here's why this is so important
so let's say that your business runs at
a twenty percent net margin which is
fine right and let's say that you
just for number sake you charge a
hundred dollars a month if you're
running a twenty percent net margin and
you're 100
a month a 20 increase in pricing would
double your profit a 50
increase in pricing with three and a
half extra profit
that's pretty good if you doubled your
price you would
6x how much money you make and so this
is how big of a lever
pricing is on how much profit you make
and so knowing how to raise your prices
obviously would be something that would
be very important so there is a right
way and a wrong way to do it
so what i want to do is show you the
right way because the wrong way to do is
send an email out saying hey we're
raising our prices you know screw you
um and you'll get a ton of customers who
leave you and then you'll end up being
worse off than you were before but i did
this
in my facility this is one of my first
businesses and i actually had a third of
my customers cancel
but i tripled my price and so i was able
to keep two thirds of my customers at
three times the price and lose one third
of my biggest
my employees called it the culling we
got rid of all the problem customers in
one fell swoop so if you have a pain
a bunch of customers were always
complaining about stuff you might want
to do this because you'll get rid of all
the cancerous people and keep only the
people who love you
and when i did that i doubled my revenue
and here's what's even cooler
my profit went through the roof because
i even had to service a third fewer
customers which was awesome all right
and so the way that we do this is uh
through a price increase letter and if
you're curious
um my gymloc secrets book is a book that
is about gyms but is a business book
that is simply applied to gyms if you
want it you can grab it
it is not how i make money um but let's
say let's let's walk through this so
you have your letter to increase prices
right now there's a format to doing this
all right now it's not about you it's
about the prospect it's about the
consumer
all right so the first thing that we
want to do right is you know we're gonna
say hey
you've probably known that we've been
you know growing a lot you've probably
noticed a lot of the
the good things that are going on right
now um and so that's why i'm writing
this letter all right so it's like
why am i doing this why am i writing
this letter to you what's the intention
the letter
all right the second is we're going to
talk about what we currently
are doing all right and so this is
allowing you
to re resell them a little bit on what
you're currently doing the value you're
currently providing them because
sometimes they forget because they might
only use
one aspect of your service and so if
they're like oh wow there's a lot of
extra stuff that i didn't even know
about and believe me i can't even tell
you the amount of times people
read this letter and they're like i
didn't even know you were doing all this
stuff right and so you want to list
out you know the stuff that you're doing
and say okay you know we hire and retain
the best talent you know we have we
offer continued education for our
employees
we you know we we're providing new uh
softwares and equipment
uh to our members that that we always
try and keep up to date that's what
we're currently doing they're like oh i
didn't even think about that so the
goal here is to is to get them to think
about your costs
try and get them into the mind of you as
an entrepreneur to the best of your you
know ability right like these are the
things that we incur
in order to provide this value it's not
like we're just taking all the money you
give us and putting it in our pockets
because that's what everyone always
thinks all right the next thing we do is
we say wow
despite all the stuff that we're doing
we want to do even more because we're
losing our minds because we just provide
crazy value
all right and so it's like we want to um
like you know we're currently
a ragtag bunch of champions our our our
facility if you have an actual facility
and if you're online it's like you know
we've got a lot of stuff that's duct
taped together
we want to really uh you know level up
the brand and we want to do it for you
right so you want to tell them what's
coming so this is like we want to add
these x y and z things we want to add
specialty programs we can add higher
levels of service
we want to add you know events to our to
our business
we want to add all these things right a
massive improvement to our level of
service
these are all things that we want to be
adding right
and then what i like to do is i like to
tie this tie this increase
to a promise of values okay now what i
mean by that is
i want to tie this to values that i
ascribe to that no one can contest so i
can say
i have made this promise to you and with
integrity i can no longer provide the
level of service
uh that i have promised unless we do
these things because i will not stand
here in this marketplace and say that we
are the best at xyz
unless we do these things and the only
way for me to do these things is for us
to have a corresponding
increase in price all right now mind you
when you're communicating the price it's
also important to communicate the price
in a way that's you know attractive so
you want to say hey it's going to cost
you
five thousand dollars extra a year you
would say it'd be better to say
uh it's going to cost you an extra 100
bucks a week right sounds like a lot
less
right you could even break down even
more and say it's 15 bucks a day it
depends on you know who we're talking to
and what level of service you have
but you can break it down to weekly or
break it down to daily and that's why
insurance quotes people in days it's
only a dollar a day right
um so that you can do this and it will
minimize what the perceived cost is so
ideally you want to maximize by saying
this is all the stuff we're doing that
we you didn't even know about
this is the stuff we want to do that's
even more than that and this is how
little it's going to cost you and the
reason we must do this is so that i
can maintain my integrity to you and the
promise that i've made you
i'm fervid that this is something i'm
planning my flag here is that i demand
to be the best in the marketplace and
for us to do this we must continually
invest and for us to do that
like this is what is required right and
then and here's what's cool
is that i like to add a little ps at the
end and that little ps
is to give perspective all right and
what i do here is i say
if this is going to materially affect
your life if you're not going to be able
to pay your mortgage you're not going to
be able to buy groceries for your kids
please reach out to me
um and we can figure something out and
so by saying that you automatically
perspective to everyone that listen no
one's gonna go homeless over this thing
right no one's gonna lose their house
because we're raising the price of our
xyz right right
but we open the door for discussion for
the people who feel obligated or feel
the need
to do this now if you make an
announcement like this which i recommend
you doing via video and via direct mail
you want to make it and then also turn
the comments off on whatever the post is
because believe me
you don't want to deal with that as you
just say hey i don't want this to be you
know a gossip form if you have anything
just bring it through me directly
out of respect for you i want to deal
with these you know face to face and not
over the keyboard right
and so it's an easier way to also manage
and mitigate any kind of negativity that
happens and believe me
if you raise your prices you're going to
have people who are going to be squeaky
wheels and it's in their best interest
to get you to not raise the prices so
just don't chicken out
once you commit to it stick with it all
right because i'm telling you if you
raise your price like i just told you if
you have a 25
margin and you raise your price by 25
you double your profit
all right so i told you i lost a third
of my customers but that's because i
tripled my price
and most businesses don't realize how
much of a pain it is to find
another one of your business and so if
you can capitalize on that and you can
usually eke out
an increase in in revenue and profit as
a result
you will be far out rewarded by making
that change and the people who do leave
are usually your worst customers and
you've been wanting to get rid of them
anyways and this gives you a great time
to do it
so if you're going to raise your prices
this is the way that i do it to existing
customers
i write a letter i tell them you know
why i'm set i'm setting the stage for
why we're doing this i tell them all the
things that we're currently doing that
they don't know that we're doing
and you probably do tons of stuff it's
good to list the stuff out then you tell
them about the future of what's going to
happen what the benefits are going to be
to them to what they're about to enjoy
and how that's going to impact them in a
real way in every single time they see
you they experience your business they
interact with
you and what benefit of the benefit is
going to occur and then finally i like
to end with
values and perspective all right so
probably values are right here
so values is kind of the wrap up so just
consider that 3.5 sorry
3.5 right and then you have your wrap up
which is hey
big picture this isn't going to make you
or break you you're not going to go
homeless because of this but if you do
have something that's going to
materially affect you because you have
that anchor it makes it very easy for
you to have that discussion
right and so if you have to raise your
prices this is how i recommend doing it
i actually have the exact letter
that we send out for for gyms in my book
if you want to grab it you can
i promise you it's not how i make my
dollars but you can get that alex's
book.com if you're curious
otherwise keep being amazing um keep
being awesome i made this channel
so that uh a lot of people are broke and
i don't want you to be one of them
that's why i made this so keep being
awesome i'll see you guys on flipside
bye